[Music]
hey everyone today we're going to
discuss the evolution of the hulk in all
his movie and tv series appearances from
1977 until now if you liked the video be
sure to leave us a like and subscribe to
the channel to not miss out on any
future content regarding your favorite
movies without further ado let's get
started
the incredible hulk is an iconic sci-fi
slash drama collection based loosely on
the legendary marvel comic superhero of
the same name it follows the story of a
certifiable genius who must come to
terms with this very upset and very
green alter ego the show revolves around
dr david banner performed by bill bixby
dr banner undertakes experimental
research after failing to save his wife
from a burning vehicle to explore why
some individuals display great
resilience when challenged with
life-threatening circumstances he is
subjected to substantial quantities of
gamma rays as a consequence of a
laboratory blunder since then every time
he's exposed to intense stress his body
is transformed and he morphs into the
incredible hulk the hulk stands
approximately seven feet tall is
massively strong and mighty and has
bright green skin dr banner transitions
back to normal human shape after
attempting to destroy whatever poses a
threat to him leaving only short-term
memory loss and raggedy apparel is proof
of what just transpired jack mcgee a
tabloid journalist creates the popular
perception that the hulk has
assassinated the doctor as a threat to
civilization and that his awareness
would advantage his professional life
banner must presume distinct personas
and wander from location to location as
a result of mcgee's ploys to undo the
impacts of the gamma radiation and
reinstate
the incredible hulk returns is a 1988
made for television movie follow-up to
the 1970s television show the incredible
hulk dr david banner who is now
established in making progress for a
research center has been capable of
delaying his transition for over seven
years he is almost done with machine the
gamma transponder that will free him of
his own gamma radiation among other
benefits this is ruined by the sudden
appearance of donald blake a former
learner who has his anguish that he
possesses a spiritual hammer having the
capability of conjuring thor a primitive
viking warrior blake summons thorin to
demonstrate the veracity of his tail the
viking god induces david to instantly
transform and a great battle between the
hulk and thor gravely harms david's
testing facility when the gamma
transponder seems to be almost hijacked
and banner's girlfriend is abducted he
must give up his hopes of being healed
and make decisions based on the hulk and
thor to save the day
the trial of the incredible hulk is a
1989 made for television movie successor
to the 1970s television series the
incredible hulk featuring the hulk and
friendly neighborhood marvel comics
personality daredevil david banner lands
in new york and boards a subway with a
woman and two men when the two men start
attacking the woman david tries to
intervene but is thrashed so he morphs
into the hulk and ends up saving her
when he turns back he is apprehended and
the woman falsely accuses david of
violently attacking her attorney matt
murdock confronts david and facilitates
his representation when he tells murdoch
he is unable to pay him murdoch conveys
his optimism that david can support him
in publicly disclosing wilson fisk an
influential career criminal david
declines to participate but murdoch
manages to convince him murdoch goes to
visit the woman but fails to encourage
her to alter her narrative someone later
attempts to kill her in her room but she
is protected by daredevil a masked
vigilante murdoch tells david that he
must be presented in court and when
david continues to refuse murdoch says
they have no other option afterwards
while still in his jail compartment
david morse into the hulk and manages to
escape david tries to flee town but
daredevil tracks him down and uncovers
himself to be murdock
the death of the incredible hulk is a
television movie that aired in 1990 it
is the third and final film based on the
1978-1982 television series the
incredible hulk david banner now known
as david bellamy camouflages himself as
a mentally ill maintenance man in order
to gain entry to a science laboratory in
oregon he appears to believe that one of
the lab's researchers ronald pratt can
assist him in conquering his
gamma-induced mutation he crawls into
the research laboratory after being
robbed at gunpoint and barely fleeing
the police a spy sabotages the research
lab during the vital test to freedom of
the hulk for good at last banner becomes
infatuated with jasmine the spy who only
works missions because her sister has
been taken captive banner and jasmine
endeavor to flee enemy forces to start
over their lives next to each other they
discover that jasmine's sister bella is
the real face of the network of spies
banner morphs into the hulk one last
time and saves jasmine but tumbles from
the plane into the night reverting to
banner yet again in his final breath
david proclaims that he is free
hulk is a 2003 superhero movie
predicated on marvel comics the film
delves into the beginnings of the hulk
which are ascribed to banner's father's
experimentations on himself and
transferring those genes onto his son
banner a bonafide mastermind with murky
family background is implicated in a
disaster that reveals him to gamma
radiation perplexed about his survival
he uncovers that whenever he becomes
frustrated he morphs into a massive
green creature wrecking everything in a
rage attack when his girlfriend betty's
father general ross is assigned the task
of containing the beast before it poses
a threat to san francisco
problems arise bruce's biological dad
starts experimenting on him to take over
bruce's power
the incredible hulk is a 2008 superhero
movie based on the marvel comics
character and is the second movie in the
marvel cinematic universe it is a
relaunch of the hulk film series in this
fresh start banner tries to search for a
remedy for the gamma radiation that
tainted his cells and set loose the
unstoppable power within him hulk having
to live in the darkness cut off from his
old life and the woman he loves betty
banner tries to protect himself from
general ross who attempts to manipulate
his strength they are challenged with
the abomination an enemy whose
capabilities surpass even hulks
banner is working as a physician in
calcutta in 2012 when he is contacted by
natasha romanov who hires him to assist
in locating the tesseract banner meets
steve rogers and shield director nick
fury he's aboard the quinn jet when tony
stark and rogers catch loki after loki's
brother thor admits to putting loki in a
compartment on shield's helicarrier
mind-controlled agents such as clint
barton strike the helicarrier causing
banner to morph into the hulk but
crumble banner later joins the avengers
in new york city following the invasion
of the chitauri banner discloses that he
is always angry quickly converting into
the hulk during the fight he combats the
chitari the words loki is stark tower
and inhibits stark from disintegrating
after losing control through the time
vortex following the battle of new york
banner asks stark to create an anti-hulk
body armor to halt him if he breaks free
banner and the avengers ransack a hydra
center in sokovia in 2015 to recoup the
scepter ultron becomes consciously aware
after a celebration party and targets
banner in the avengers at the tower
before escaping banner and the avengers
endeavor to halt ultron but are toned
down by wanda maximoff who stimulates
the hulk to stampede through the city
until stark decides to stop him with his
hulkbuster body armor fury persuades the
avengers to formulate a strategy to
block ultron which leads to romanov's
capture and shipping to sokovia banner
forsakes the team to save romanov and
morphs into the hulk to confront ultron
the hulk moves away in a quinjet after
the final confrontation with ultron in
sokovia
the quinjet collapses on the disposal
planet zakar after hulk is stranded in
space thor blows up on sakhar in 2017
and after being seized by valkyrie he
faces hulk in his final battle thor
receives the upper hand over hulk but
the grandmaster dismantles the fight to
guarantee hulk's triumph thor strives to
persuade hulk to help him save asgard
from ragnarok before escaping the palace
for the first time in two years he
reverts to bruce banner banner is
surprised to discover that he is in
space and worries that if he morphs back
into the hulk he won't be capable of
returning to his human form banner and
thor team up with valkyrie and loki to
escape zakar to asgard where banner
morphs back into hulk and saves as
guardians from fenris as surtour wrecks
asgard the hulk boards a ship to earth
in 2018 hulk faces thanos but he is
outmatched heimdall sends hulk directly
to earth via the bifrost bridge and hulk
crash lands on the sanctum santorum of
steven strange and wong ebony ma and kul
obsidian arrive in new york in search of
the time stone banner joins the avengers
in wakanda where he combats the
outriders with stark's hulkbuster body
armor and overpowers obsidian banner
survives the blip after thanos
stimulates the infinity gauntlet and
translocates away he returns with the
surviving victims to the planet titan 2
to encounter thanos
banner goes through gamma
experimentation between 2018 and 2023 to
control his two sides by 2023 he is
forever in the body of the hulk but with
banner's brain and voice the attempt but
fail to time travel lang at the avengers
compound using the small quantum
corridor banner and rocket tried to
persuade a depressed thor to return to
the avengers the avengers develop an
approach for time travel and fetching
substitute infinity stones banner roger
stark and lang use the quantum realm to
make the journey to an alternate 2012 in
new york city ben requires the time
stone for an enhanced version of the
ancient one there when banner returns to
the present he nullifies the blip but
his right arm is forever wounded as a
result as a consequence a substitute
thanos arises from the quantum world and
targets the compound he then battles
thanos who is finally defeated when
stark utilizes the infinity stones after
the battle banner builds a fresh quantum
portal for rogers to return the
substitute infinity stones and mjolnir
benner reverts to his human shape some
years later and now appears to be
wearing a shoulder strap because of the
injury he suffered after shang chi uses
the ten rings the rings eject a
mysterious beam provoking wong to
consult banner and carol danvers via
projection to analyze it with shang qi
she-hulk attorney at law is one of the
many upcoming marvel initiatives and
will be the titular protagonist's mcu
debut it pursues jennifer walters a
gentle attorney who specializes in
superhuman cases bruce banner's hulk
will also appear in the series as her
mentor to teach her all things hulk
related she-hulk attorney at law is set
to officially launch on august 18th 2022
and will run for nine episodes before
ending on october 13 2022
it for today what is your favorite hulk
appearance during the years and what are
your expectations of the she-hulk series
let us know in the comments down below
be sure to leave us a like if you
enjoyed the video and subscribe for more
content on the biggest upcoming
blockbusters until next time
[Music]
you